he's just 17 years old but Jacob jusnow
embroiled in one of Hong Kong's most
shocking
violence
the police he shows us a picture which
still fills him with fear
he's just been brutally arrested his
head is oozing blood and he's terrified
about what's going to happen next I say
sorry to police at that time because I
was frightened and I really scared that
they won't see me to a hospital or they
just assign me territory to the police
this is the night it happened the school
kids have just left a peaceful protest
but panic sets in has been stealing the
subway station the boy in the blue
t-shirt is Jacob Chu like the others
who've petrified of the police a
different angle moments later sees Jacob
running right into the advance of these
bleep
he tries to shield his head as the
police put him to the ground
you can see already there's blood on the
floor from his head wound as he's cuffed
one of the police run I like my white
legs and the other police try to use
this time to hit my body like my back my
hat and my white legs and I thought that
they'd come by they forced me down
earlier on the subway station had been
filled with young people some of whom
were seen vandalizing the turnstiles
but Jacob Chu is spotted several times
here to the left of the screen he's
wandering around watching the ground in
another shot he's seen walking towards
the exit where the Lisa just about to
enter just peacefully and doing nothing
but I think that the police were mad and
I think that they can control their
emotions as they enter you can see Jacob
- on the Left trapped between two sets
of police with nowhere to go
I don't exactly know how many the times
that need a hit when it counts remember
I will say as constant well I can't
sleep
at the first two days and when I woke up
the baddest all that because I think I
was worthy frightened and some poets are
standing outside my bed at the hospital
and I think I feel scared he was in
hospital for two weeks with stitches on
his head a broken hand and now a burning
desire for justice actually we we did
nothing wrong but that the police and
the government
sure apologize
to
and say sorry to what they did which is
totally wrong
Jacob Chu is highly unusual he's spoken
out most are too scared
he was released without charge one of a
growing number of cases which have
deeply disturbed human rights lawyers
Alex Crawford Sky News Hong Kong